This is a message from New Zealand.
If I could encourage the world to do one thing, it would be...
It'd be pretty hard to explain.
It would be to listen very carefully to each other.
Take a look at what's going on around you...
...and see if you can do something about it.
If I could encourage the world to do one thing,...
...it would be to stop polluting the Earth.
Go to the library you know.
Education is good.
Yep.
Live life to its fullest.
Always be a good boy.
It would be to stay positive.
To know our neighbors and to be part of a community.
To learn as much as you can about where you are in life.
And look after our planet, a hell of a lot better.
It might displode so that's why we always pick up rubbish.
Get off your bum and go for a walk.
Be honest.
Tell me how you really feel.
Yeah.
Believe in yourself.
Look up at the night sky on a clear, starry night...
...and realize the universe that we're all part of.
Stay safe.
I love you, los amo.
That we all just work together and be one.
Anything is possible when you try.